a couple of months ago on the first day
of a major Islamic religious holiday a
man casually walked up to a mosque in
Stockholm Sweden and with hundreds of
people looking on he produced a Koran
and began ripping out the pages he wiped
a few of those pages on his shoe and
then the man set the Quran on fire
five thousand miles away at the U.S
state Department Joe Biden's diplomats
sprang into action within hours the
state department issued the strongest
possible condemnation of the Quran
burning quote I will say that we do
condemn it so the state department
spokesman spokesman added that the the
demonstration had created quote an
environment of fear that will quote
impact the ability of Muslims and
members of other religious minority
groups from freely exercising their
right to freedom of religion or belief
in Sweden now whatever you think of that
response you have to admit it's a little
bit surprising because it was just two
years ago that criminals torched
vandalized and looted more than 80
churches across Canada unlike Sweden
Canada sits directly on the border of
the United States some churches that
went up in Flames are a 10-minute drive
from major population centers in this
country
and yet as the churches were raised Joe
Biden State Department didn't say a word
one Quran burning in Sweden gets their
attention the destruction of dozens of
entire churches a few miles north of the
U.S border well they couldn't be
bothered by that
neither could Canada's prime minister
Justin Trudeau as his country witnessed
this historic campaign of anti-christian
terrorism two years ago a campaign that
somehow led to just one arrest
Trudeau said the violence was
unacceptable but also understandable
watch
as I've also said uh it is unacceptable
and wrong that acts of vandalism and
arson are are being seen across the
country including against Catholic
churches
one of my Reflections is I understand
the anger that's out there against the
federal government against institutions
like the Catholic Church it is real and
it is fully understandable given the
shameful history that we're all becoming
more and more aware of and engaging
ourselves to do better as Canadians
but I can't help but think
that
burning down churches
is actually depriving people who are
in need of grieving and healing and
mourning from places where they can
actually grieve and reflect and look for
support
we shouldn't be lashing out at buildings
that can provide Solace to some of our
fellow citizens
it's understandable Justice Joe says as
thugs torch Christian churches in his
country
he ignores the attack of Christianity in
his country just as politicians the
United States ignore the deadly mass
shooting by a trans terrorist at a
Christian school in Nashville earlier
this year and just as they ignored the
campaign of terrorism directed against
pro-life pregnancy centers in all these
cases elected officials didn't simply
excuse violence against Christians
instead for years with the help of
corporate media these officials
engineered hoaxes for the purpose of
demonizing Christians and encouraging
more of this kind of violence the point
of these hoaxes was to create a pretext
for the violence that inevitably
followed in every single case
in the U.S The hoax took the form of
disingenuous warnings about trans
genocide and entirely fictional epidemic
of anti-trans murders murders that turn
out in nearly every case to be related
to domestic disputes drugs prostitution
and have nothing to do with the fact
that the victim identifies as Trans in
Canada The hoax that prompted the church
burnings began in Earnest in May of 2021
when Canadian media reported that ground
penetrating radar had found the unmarked
Graves of more than 200 children near an
Indian residential school in Kamloops
which is located in British Columbia
and many of the media reports and social
media posts actually referred to these
alleged sites as mass Graves
the Canadian government had established
these residential schools in the 19th
century to assimilate native Canadian
children into Canadian culture they were
mainly operated and funded by the Roman
Catholic Presbyterian methodists and
Anglican churches now leftists in Canada
have long maintained that these schools
mistreated children that's been
conventional wisdom for some time in
Canada that's one of the reasons
Canadian activists now argue that Canada
should strip Catholic schools of all
federal funding and these supposed Mass
Graves were the confirmation that they
needed
the evidence to support the narrative
that they already believed
now to be clear it's long been suspected
that children did die of diseases like
tuberculosis and influenza at these
schools it's also true that in that time
period countless children of all Races
ethnicities across the entire world died
of these diseases but the discovery of
supposed Mass Graves at one of these
schools to the media and the Canadian
government
meant something very different
the finding they suggested meant that
Christians had systematically murdered
children at these schools and then
covered up the evidence
the Toronto Star reported the remains of
215 children have been found
the AP reported over 600 bodies founded
another Catholic school for indigenous
children in Canada
U.S news and many other outlets called
it confirmation of quote genocide
Etc
within days the reports that ground
penetrating radar had found unmarked
Graves at residential school sites all
over Canada this was a widespread
epidemic they told us
here's a Bloomberg report on an
additional Discovery watch
we started our radar penetrating
research on June the 2nd of 2021.
as of yesterday
we have hit
751 unmarked Graves
this is not a mass grave site these are
unmarked Graves this is now today on
causes First Nation
and this is what we call today our
community gravesite
it became our community gravesite after
the 1970s when the residential school
was stopped overseen by the Roman
Catholic church and the Archdiocese
you're going to notice that they are in
proper order
these that lay here
are one meter by one meter apart in some
cases
so there were dozens of reports like
this all throughout the summer of 2021
this was the reporting from the entire
news media in the U.S and Canada and in
response to Justin Trudeau knelt at one
of the supposed grave sites and
pretended to cry Canada celebrations
were canceled
the government pledged hundreds of
millions of dollars to investigate this
there were Mass protests statues were
toppled
one Outlet says that uh that says it
serves indigenous communities aptn news
reported that quote demonstrators
toppled statues of Queen Victoria and
Queen Elizabeth in Winnipeg during
rallies honoring the children discovered
in unmarked Graves on the sites of
former residential schools over the past
month
and here's what that looked like watch
[Applause]
now in the eyes of these Riders Queen
Elizabeth represents colonialism and
colonialism means taking advantage of
the natives not helping them
this anti-colonialist narrative is
absurdly simplistic it ignores the
actual facts of History so naturally
they want to destroy all remnants of
that history starting with the statues
this was the mainstream position on the
Canadian left Harsha Walia the executive
director of the British Columbia civil
liberties Association which is basically
Canada's version of the ACLU encouraged
the vandals she declared quote burn it
all down
two years later
the lies that these barbarians have been
telling have completely Fallen apart
no Mass Graves have been found at the
supposed unmarked grave sites that have
allegedly been uncovered with ground
penetrating radar no bodies
no remains have been Unearthed none at
all it was all a hoax
the alleged gravesite and cam loops it
turns out that we told you about at the
beginning that was the site of a septic
field which was used to dispose the of
the the school's sewage the school dug a
massive line of trenches three feet deep
for that purpose but the researchers
quote unquote who scanned the site with
ground penetrating radar somehow weren't
aware of that
I mean how could they miss that little
detail how could they fail to consider
other potential reasons why a school
might dig trenches
how was a mass grave the very first and
only assumption
remember the radar never detected bodies
okay ground penetrating radar can't do
that he detected anomalies
and anomaly just means something
unexpected or strange something out of
place
well if there's something unexpected in
the ground something out of place
why would you assume that the thing must
be a a grave of dead children
are there other possibilities you should
consider first
using the internet without expressvpn
it's like checking in your baggage at
the airport without a lock you think
your stuff is kept private but you never
know who's going through your things
when you go online without a VPN
internet service providers can see every
single website you visit they can
legally sell this information without
your consent to ad companies to Tech
Giants who then use your data to Target
you when you use expressvpn internet
service providers cannot see your online
activity your identity is anonymized by
a secure VPN server your data is also
encrypted for maximum protection I love
expressvpn because of how easy it is to
use just fire up the app and click one
button plus it works on all your devices
like phones laptops even routers so
everyone who shares your Wi-Fi can be
protected secure your online activity by
visiting expressvpn.com Walsh right now
to get three extra months free that's
exp rssvpn.com Walsh to get protected
today expressvpn.com Walsh
in two years nobody in Canadian State
media has bothered to ask that question
instead they've sought to discredit
anyone who doubts the false narrative as
recently as this summer the state media
Outlet CBC ran this headline quote
residential school denialists tried to
dig up suspected unmarked Graves and cam
loops
the Toronto Star wrote last year
genocide deniers ask where are the
bodies of the residential school
children
seems like a good question to me
I mean if you're saying there's a
genocide and there should be a lot of
bodies and if you can't find the bodies
then that would call into question the
genocide wouldn't it
one senior Member of Parliament Mark
Miller argued that Canadians who ask
questions are quote part of a pattern of
denialism and Distortion in other words
seeking verifiable evidence of the
media's claims is somehow denialism
by asking to verify the facts you are
distorting the facts
it's precisely what they do with climate
change they make these outlandish
unsupported claims and then when you
look into the claims at all they call
you a denier
and what happens to deniers well you can
probably guess
if you're not on their side of the issue
then you might go to prison
this summer as John K reported at
Colette the investigator appointed by
Trudeau to investigate these Graves
called on the government to give quote
urgent consideration to quote civil and
criminal sanctions against Residential
School quote denialism
and if we take that proposal seriously
and there are signs that the Canadian
government will
then ironically it could mean a lot of
natives are about to go to prison
because in their efforts to prove their
theory of residential school Mass grades
these natives are inadvertently
debunking it
somebody calling himself Chief Derek
napanak of the uh of one Indian tribe
just decided to dig up some Graves at a
residential school in Manitoba this is a
school that just a few weeks ago was
reported to be the site of 14 possible
burial sites quote unquote
well here's what the chief found at this
burial site watch
July 24th would be the start of our
continuing search for truth as we move
from identifying 14 Reflections in the
ground underneath the Catholic Church to
an actual excavation of the site
our elders residential school survivors
and community members requested that we
move in this Direction together
following Community engagement over the
past two years
the excavation would be an effort to
determine the truth of the reflections
identified by ground penetrating radar
that was done twice over this location
in the past 12 months to lead to Greater
certainty of the extent and location of
the reflections
we are now concluding the excavation of
the 14 locations under the church
the archaeological team we hired from
the University of Brandon which is the
same archaeological team that is relied
upon by Regional Police agencies when
doing archaeological excavations
found no conclusive evidence of human
remains in their excavation of the
ground under the church basement
as a community we were preparing for
more than one possible outcome which
meant that we would prepare for the
worst but we would hope for the best
we know from the living memory of our
elders who attended the school as well
as the living memory of those who have
been past the stories of their ancestors
experiences in the school that horrible
things happen there
so there's a big build up and all the
disclaimers before he gets around to the
reveal
which is that the ground penetrating
radar hadn't picked up unmarked Graves
at all
in fact it picked up a bunch of oddly
shaped rocks
alas it turns out more than a dozen
children had not been buried under this
school now you think that because for
celebration
I mean this man just confirmed that
children had not in fact been murdered
and stuffed underground while attending
a school many years ago
to most people that's an uplifting
development that's a relief
when you think that there's a you know
unmarked Graves of children and then you
you dig and you find a bunch of rocks a
normal person says well thank God
hey I got great news everybody turns out
that a bunch of kids were not killed
here
that's good
but that's not what you see in that
amazing video
instead the chief is clearly bothered by
the discovery or lack thereof
says he's worried the nihilists might
use reality to undermine his activism
and his quest for victimhood
the lack of dead children in the ground
worries him think about that
you know he says there yeah you hope for
the best but prepare for the worst
you have to ask yourself like what is
the best and worst in your mind
this sounds to me you're saying the the
worst scenario is that you don't find
unmarked Graves of children
hey you hope for the best that you'll
find a bunch of dead kids in the ground
that's really the attitude these people
have
and he concludes by insisting that
despite this little setback with his
theory everyone knows that the Canadian
residential school system was abusive
everyone knows the Christians treated
these kids horribly he says
do we know that
what reason do we have to believe that
exactly
the Canadian government and media just
spent two years lying about an obviously
falsifiable story which is that there
were Mass Graves at these schools
okay the media and the government
said that that because there are unknown
objects under the ground at a church it
must be a bunch of dead children and
could not possibly be anything else
and then it turns out that that was that
was a bunch of BS that's what just
happened
they lied about genocide when they knew
people could simply dig up the graves
and prove them wrong so why should we
believe anything they have to say about
how horribly these schools will run for
centuries
if these schools were so horrible why
did they have to concoct a blatant
grotesque lie about them
if they're really really bad but they
weren't killing kids and they didn't
have mass Graves why just tell the truth
tell us what really happened
well now we can't believe anything you
say
you know when they when they when they
uh shift the the uh the goal posts here
and they say okay well yeah there's not
a bunch of unmarked Graves but here's a
bunch of bad things that did happen
guess what I'm going to do I'm going to
say I don't care what else you say it
doesn't I don't believe any of that and
that's what the rest of us will do now
you don't get to just shift the goal
post and say okay fine we're wrong about
this but we're right about this
nope don't believe any of it don't
believe any of it
you know if you didn't want people to
ask questions
skeptical questions you could be honest
with them
you could do the exact opposite of what
these cretans are doing
lying like this creates chaos it derails
any possibility of a reasonable
fact-based conversation about what
actually happened at these schools and
it's almost as if they're doing it on
purpose
almost
now it's tempting to dismiss all this
and say well it's only happening in
Canada which is a uniquely Godless place
and at some level that's true Canada is
one of the few Nations on Earth to
permit abortion up to the moment of
birth one of the only places on Earth
where people who don't even have
terminal illnesses can be euthanized
like stray dogs that level of savagery
is exceptional but
on this issue as with so many others the
left in this country agrees with
Canadian liberals recall that a year
before the Canadian Church burnings
rioters in this country torched St
John's Church across from the White
House
nobody on the left even pretended to
care
When Donald Trump tried to tour the
damage they called him a fascist
the kind of people I'm talking about
here are not confined to Canada and
their goal is not simply to win
elections their goal is to destroy the
foundation of Western Civilization most
notably Christianity
and in the face of this effort virtually
no one is pushing back
no one is asking questions
not even the Vatican in fact the pope
has apologized to these Canadian
activists
he went on a pilgrimage of repentance
over Canada's residential schools
what did that accomplish
nothing of course
cultural vandals will forget that
they're forget their own lies the moment
they're disproven move on to the next
one
that's what they always do
but they'll never forget weakness once
they see it
they'll never be deterred by anyone who
doesn't tell the truth about what
they're doing
so here's the truth
like Justin Trudeau Joe Biden's handlers
hate Catholics they hate Western
Civilization
and they'll use whatever Hammer is
available to beat us over the heads
and they'll even use some hammers that
aren't available that they have to make
up
they are spiritual enemies
and it's time to stop giving them the
upper hand
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code walls
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there